parmi les passions de jeunesse que j'ai
conservée en grandissant je pense qu'on
peut placer très haut
les dinosaures c'est un peu la faute de
jurassic park et puis de cette
collection magazine qui rappellera
peut-être des souvenirs à certains
j'ai suivi l'évolution des théories sur
leur posture est ce qu'ils avaient des
plumes pas de plumes
est ce que monsieur me et leurs
descendants et comment ont-ils disparu
et puis j'avais mon petit préféré aussi
du coup et bien que les dinosaures soin
des animaux badass à eux tous seuls
aujourd'hui on va parler d' une des
pionnières en paléontologie du 19e
siècle
mary anning marie est née en 1799 dans
le sud de l'angleterre
rien à voir avec les 10 nommés à un an
elle est frappée par la foudre avec
quatre autres personnes est la seule
survivante la vie trouve toujours un
chemin
la légende raconte que l'éclair l'aurait
rendu plus intelligente mais là en tant
qu'historienne je dis stop
elle grandit en plein durant l'époque de
la folie des fossiles le village où elle
vit en est très riche en plus d'être une
station balnéaire réputée avec son père
et son frère il ramasse dès son enfance
des ammonites et autres pour les
revendre aux touristes et arrondir ainsi
des fins de mois lorsque son père meurt
alors qu'elle n'a que 11 ans la
recherche de fossiles devient le seul
moyen de subvenir à la famille et elle
s'y consacre à plein temps avec son
frère même si son but est d'abord
commercial la collecte de fossiles se
transforme progressivement en sciences
au début du 19e siècle les découvertes
importantes de marie attire l'intérêt
des collectionneurs géologue et
paléontologues en 1811 elle trouve un
fossile complet dicter aux ors de 10
mètres de long alors qu'elle n'a que 12
ans il s'agit du premier squelette
complet de cette espèce découvert qui
attire l'attention du collectionneur
thomas spear ch
en 1820 il décide de mettre aux enchères
sa propre collection au profit de la
famille hanning pour les sortir du
besoin
en 1821 et 1823 et découvre deux
squelettes de plésiosaure les premiers
jamais observée ces découvertes
permettent de confirmer l'existence de
cette espèce et lui valent encore une
fois la reconnaissance de la communauté
scientifique
cette jeune anglaise par son zèle et son
intelligence a sucré avec ces objets un
commerce aussi utile pour la science
qu'il est honorable et lucratif pour
elle en 1828 elle trouve aussi le
premier squelette de ptérosaure hors
d'allemagne
les découvertes des plésiosaures et du
petit rose or sont ses principales
contributions à la paix l'ontologie mais
elle continue ses recherches jusqu'à la
fin de sa vie elle découvre entre autres
un bel est ni un invertébré proche du
calamar un squale au raja entre le
requin et l'art est une autre sorte de
plésiosaure elle tient une boutique où
elle vend ses découvertes à des
collectionneurs aux scientifiques et
touchent une rente annuelle de
l'association britannique pour
l'avancement des sciences et des fonds
gouvernementaux
grâce à ses recherches et à celle de ses
contemporains elle permet d'attester
l'idée que des espèces inconnues vivait
sur la terre les maires et dans le ciel
durant l'âge des reptiles et se sont
éteintes il ya bien longtemps
cette idée avait été émise à la fin du
xviiie siècle par cuvier était encore
très contestée notamment par l'église
puisqu'elle envoyer bouler l'idée que la
terre n'avait que 4 millions et des
poussières des poussières de dinosaures
toutefois ces découvertes exposées dans
les musées et des collections privées
mentionne rarement son nom les articles
scientifiques basés sur ces découvertes
ne la mentionne pas non plus marie était
une femme issue d'une classe populaire
et elle essaie trop peu décrit elle-même
pour être reconnu comme scientifique la
société géologique de londres n'accepte
alors pas les femmes que ce soit en tant
que membre ou qu'invité elle y est
finalement intégré comme membre
honoraire en 1846 un an avant sa mort
d'un cancer du sein plusieurs espèces
fossiles porte son nom et beaucoup de
ces découvertes peuvent encore être
observé dans des musées du monde entier
bien que son nom reste rarement cités
c'est pourquoi j'ai décidé de lui rendre
hommage dans cet épisode dieu créé les
videurs dieu détruit les dinosaures
dieu créa l'homme l'homme détruit dieu
l'homme créé les dinosaures les
dinosaures mon ange l'homme la femme
hérite la terre